Hey youtubers it’s charlie and can we just
talk about sansa for a little while.
I don’t think she’s doing so hot...I mean
welcome to my game of thrones season 4 preview
for sansa stark.
Let’s talk a little about where season 3
left her and look at some of the castings
and the second half of book 3 and try to figure
out what her story is going to be in season
4.
So at the end of season 3 Sansa got her storybook
wedding finally.
To Tyrion.
Oh Wait, no that was like the worst, most
uncomfortable wedding ever.
Followed by the worst wedding night ever.
In my season 4 tyrion preview I kind of compared
tyrion and sansa because they occupy the same
place in the story right now.
So I guess it is kind of fitting that they
ended up together.
Obviously I don’t expect that to last for
too long, remember Tyrion was under strict
orders to deflower her and he didn’t and
Littlefinger and Varys both have plans for
her.
Everyone is kind of trying to pull Sansa in
a different direction or shoot her with a
crossbow for sport.
Based on the new minor characters that have
been cast for season 4 and the events of book
4 I think that Sansa will end up in the Eyrie
at the end of the season.
We haven’t been there since season 1, but
remember Littlefinger is headed there and
he has plans to take Sansa with him.
I felt like in the books Sansa was kind of
a bystander to all the drama in the rest of
the big things that will be happening in Season
4.
Her story really picks up after this seasons
quote unquote red wedding episode.
I don’t know when that moment is going to
come but I don’t think they’ll wait till
the end of the season to do it.
Doesn’t it always seem like all of the major
characters on game of thrones go through a
lot of the same situations.
First they start out in this really safe place
with a lot of control over their surroundings,
then they get betrayed and that sense of control
turns out to be an illusion, then they go
on the run, then they find some respite before
things keep getting worse and worse.
Thematically I think this just fits nicely
with the Winter is Coming idea.
Remember, in a song of ice and fire, we’re
not even half way through the story.
And we’re not even close to Winds of Winter,
which is presumably when the army of white
walkers will start to do battle with Stannis
and the rest of westeros.
So if it seems like Sansa, Theon, Tyrion,
Jaime and everyone else have it bad right
now.
Expect everyone else to get dumped on before
we start seeing frost blades in king’s landing.
Let me know what you think will happen to
Sansa this season, will she make it out of
King’s Landing, and what is Littlefinger
going to do with her once they make it to
the eyrie.
I feel like that place is like another harrenhaal
even though it’s not melted by dragonfire.
There are a couple notable events that I’m
pretty sure will happen.
Littlefinger will help Sansa escape King’s
Landing and they will make it to the Eyrie.
And I think that Littlefinger will show Lysa
Arryn the moon door at the very end of the
season.
One of the things that frustrated me in the
books was that Sansa’s story kind of stops
short during book 4.
Littlefinger kind of lures her away with the
promise that he’ll help her reclaim Winterfell
by marrying Lysa Arryn’s son.
You remember him, he’s totally not weird
at all.
But I guess anyone is a step up from crossbow
here.
Either way it’s not going to get better
for Sansa anytime soon.
But, let me know what some of your favorite
things are about her character.
I feel like Sophie Turner has really matured
as an actress on the show.
The character she’s playing isn’t given
a lot of big moments, so it kind of falls
on her as an actress to fill in a lot of the
blanks.
By popular demand my next season 4 preview
will be for Jon Snow, be sure to subscribe
to get it.
That video will post on Monday.
Remember I’m also in the middle of my attack
on titan marathon and Legend of Korra is back
tonight, so I will be posting a review video
for that late tonight.
If you really want to help me out then please
like and share this video.
And you can check out my other season 4 previews
by clicking here and you can check out my
review of the first couple of episodes of
attack on titan by clicking here.
Thanks for watching, high fives!